okay hello everyone and hope you are
enjoying the conference so far if you
are not you can blame me yes so my name
is Mattie Lehrer and the talk was
originally titled evaluating
unsupervised models but as I was making
the slides and I sort of figured that
I'll only have time to talk about topic
models so now you only hear about topic
models
there's my Twitter account if you want
to tweet at me there is a there is a
companion notebook that goes with the
talk and it has quite a lot more detail
on the things I'm going to say you can
find it from my github page I'll try to
get it posted on the berliner pilot org
blog as well so this talk is really an
overview of what's available for
evaluating topic models there's quite a
lot of links to relevant literature as
well as software which is why the
companion notebook exists you don't have
to try to write everything down now you
can just go to the notebook and you'll
find all the references there I'm going
to cover quite a lot of material and the
aim here really is to give you an
intuition for why the metrics exist and
what is it that they're trying to
measure so I'm not going to go into
detail in actually almost anything but
just try to give you some kind of an
understanding of why we have these
metrics and what are they trying to do
now focus on tools that are available
that are open-source and also research
papers that are open access so this is
not an exhaustive list of everything
just a summary it's three parts I'll
start off with just eyeballing the
models so evaluating for yourself
whether you got something reasonable or
not then some intrinsic evaluation
metrics and then some metrics that are
based on human judgments essentially
trying to capture into a metric what the
first part with the eye balling does
there's an obvious omission here which
is extrinsic evaluation metrics if
you're doing say document classification
with the topic model well then the
document classification task itself is
your evaluation metric
you'll need to know whether or not the
topic model has captured some semantic
information you just optimize whatever
classification metric you want to use
and as long as the topic model performs
well on the task well that's all you
care about right so there's quite a lot
of different kinds of topic models and I
expect you to have some kind of an
understanding of what topic models are
how they work
I'm not going to cover any of that in
anyway the idea is that they work on a
corpus of documents so the context for
doing all of the inference is a single
document however it's somewhat poorly
defined what a document means it can be
anything from a sentence like a tweet to
a paragraph in a book or a chapter and
so on once you get a model you run new
documents through that and you get a
decomposition of the kinds of of the
topics that are contained in that new
document and yet as I said there's
there's quite a lot of different models
that you can use this talk the way you
evaluate the model is it doesn't matter
which way you use to infer the model the
kind of information that you would wish
to get out is pretty much the same
regardless of the algorithm you use so
this talk is it doesn't really matter
whether you're using Lda or pls AI VLSI
or it's very glaze DB or whatever so
this is usually what you would want to
have it's you have a bunch of document
so each dot here is supposed to be a
single document and there are all sort
of neatly clustered entities into these
sort of discrete groups of documents and
you can sort of point to a cluster and
go right that's machine learning and
that sport and that's this and that's
that you can also see that the so it's
captured some sort of the representation
here you know tennis and sport are close
together so they're kind of in the same
part of the semantic space whatever that
means this is usually however what you
get so this is a topic model that I
trained on the fake news data set
available on Kegel link is in
the notebook and you can see that we've
captured some structure here so topic 9
for instance is clearly related to the
Dakota access pipeline protests
there's also topic 11 Flint water crisis
there's something related to Russia and
weapons in NATO and so on so there's
some structure there but evaluating this
evaluating whether this has actually
captured all the things that you want it
to is is cumbersome at best how do you
know if did the model meets something
that was in the corpus and you're just
not seeing it this also takes a lot of
time okay so okay I said part of that so
you want to evaluate the model to find
out whether the whether whether the
model has really like captured the
internal semantic structure that you
have in the corpus that's kind of the
end goal usually what you have here you
want to know if the topics are
understandable maybe we can quantify
that somehow whether they are coherent
do they like overlap with each other a
lot are they missing topics and so on
and then ultimately the evaluation that
you do is the utility that the topic
model has for you so if if you are using
the topic model for instance just to
understand the kind of semantic
structure of a corpus well then then the
ultimate evaluation metric is how much
did the model further your understanding
of the semantic structure of the corpus
that is of course difficult to put a
fixed number on but it's good to keep in
mind that that that subjective measure
is the thing that we are actually
wanting to make measure okay so then
looking at the sort of lists of top
words from a model is a little bit
cumbersome so what are some tools that
can help with with that kind of
exploration so here's a bunch of
research from the Stanford based group
the first paper focuses on on on kind of
re-ranking the top words from the model
so in the previous table
you saw a sample of six top words from
from each topic and on the left here you
see words and here are topics just
labeled with a topic number and the
terms are ranked by their sort of
overall corpus frequency and you can see
that there's really no like you can't
really pick out any immediate structure
here then on the right you see the
methods that they develop in the paper
there's a few different metrics that
they actually developed this particular
one is uses kind of conditional
probabilities on the kind of on the sort
of pairwise conditional probabilities on
how likely the words are to occur and
close together within a window and you
can see that the you can hopefully see
that the method that they've developed
it preserves word order so you have
things like aspect ratio and social
networks and so on maintain their order
within the ranking but you also see that
the ranking kind of reveals these
clusters that are semantically coherent
so this blue cluster is about sort of
social networks and network analysis and
so on so that gives you a much better
understanding much faster of what what
the model has captured then the second
paper moves on to the document level and
they're basically doing the same thing
but for documents and now so here you
see labeled a labelled reference corpus
so these are the gathered information
from domain experts they asked them to
define through keywords what how is the
their domain kind of what kind of
keywords capture their domain and then
they also asked them to like label give
them some example documents from
research papers that like here's some
representative research from this field
and so on so that allowed them to build
this reference corpus and then they
build the topic model and then you can
see that there's some topics that map on
to several kind of reference concepts
there's also some reference concepts
that map onto
several topics so it's one one concept
is split into several topics or one
topic is trying to model two different
reference concepts and so on and there's
also like this missing reference
concepts there's information that that
exists in the corpus but the topic model
has not captured okay so that is that
then I move on to LD IVs which was
originally an r package and there is no
Python port of that this is another sort
of interactive tool so this term ID
stuff this is actually available on
github for you to play around with the
pile the Avis is another interactive
tool so you get an HTML output that you
can then open in your browser and the
way this works is you have your semantic
document romantic topic space on the
left and your sort of word term space on
the right and this so the proximity of
these bubbles here so each circle is a
single topic and the proximity is
supposed to reflect the semantic
proximity of those topics or the first
picture that you saw of the ideal case
this is trying to capture that so this
is one sort of discrete set of kind of
concepts and this is another set of
different concepts and so the way you
use this is you can highlight a word and
then when you highlight a word you can
see that there's a bunch of topics where
this word is very sort of prevalent
where it's used a lot or it plays it
it's important in these particular
topics and you can see that when you
highlight Clinton or indeed when you
highlight Trump the same sort of area
over all of the topic space gets
highlighted so this is right this is the
same fake news data set from Kegel we're
clearly talking about US politics
there's another way to use it you can
also flip this around and you can select
or highlight just a topic and once you
do that the list of terms changes here
so if I go back to the previous slide
you have one set of one set of words
when you select a topic you get a
different set of terms which is these
are now specifically related to that
topic ranked in terms of how important
they are to this one topic okay so this
gives you another way to sort of
interactively poke the model and
relatively quickly sort of figure out
whether it captured something
interesting what that might be and so on
there's a few problems however first of
all the so the river
I forgot to say so these the sizes of
the circles represents the importance of
that topic in the model flash corpus so
how much of this topic does the corpus
overall contain you get a sort of a
general understanding of yeah okay some
topics are more important than others
the problem is that it's really
difficult to determine the relative
sizes of the circles this is now this is
a different model but it illustrates the
point this is from the pie Lda this
example notebook
now topic 1 here is clearly the most
important but can you tell what the
relative importance between 10 and 15 is
the reason for why this is bad it's
nothing to do with peyote haze as such
or Lda vs as such it's just really
difficult to determine the relative
sizes of circles this is can you tell
what what the area of these circles is
with relation to it to each other are
they is this 10 times the area of that
or is it two times or five times that's
the actual answer so the blue circle is
twice the area of the orange one and the
blue circle is actually five times the
area of the green one
so you can't really like it's just
difficult for humans to determine that
mainly because of this because the area
grows is the square of the radius it's
really difficult to make those
distinctions just visually the other
problem is that the semantic proxy or
the proximity in this topic space is
also like it does capture something but
it's also somewhat arbitrary yes okay so
your question is on the graph what are
the axes I'll explain this just now so
this is supposed to capture the semantic
similarity of topic so some topics go
here and some topics go there now the
problem is that there's various
different ways to do because this is
obviously two-dimensional well the
topics aren't two-dimensional so this is
projected from the projected down from
the sort of inter topic similarity
matrix down into two dimensions now
there's two different there's three
different algorithms for doing that
projection on the Left you see principal
coordinates Alice's and on here you see
metric multi-dimensional scaling again
the question is are topics 10 and 15
close together or far apart are they
semantically similar or semantically not
similar now these the other problem
relating to your question is that yet so
these two axes are the principal
components but that's also somewhat
meaningless in this context you don't
like these might might as well not be
there it doesn't the axes don't give you
any information you also lose all sense
of scale because the size of the circles
and the location of the circles are not
related to each other in any way so
while the tool did I answer your
question
these these axes should not be here
they're completely meaningless it's a
projection from a multi to high
dimensional space on the two dimensions
it depends on how it depends on how many
topics you have so it's a it's a
pairwise topic to topic similarity
metric similarity matrix project it down
onto two dimensions but it what those
two dimensions are you don't know sorry
you would hope so but it depends on the
algorithm that you use it depends on
whatever whether you're using this or
that it depends on what the algorithm
actually gives you as an output so you
need to understand like in order to
really understand what these axes mean
you need to look into the details of how
the projection algorithm works and what
the output of that is okay so then let's
move on to intrinsic evaluation which
will hopefully give us a better
understanding of what the model has done
if you look online you will often be
pointed to using perplexity don't use
perplexity the problem is that
perplexity doesn't like it comes from
the sort of from the language modeling
community and it doesn't capture the
kind of semantic information that we
want if you look at what like ignore
everything left from here that's just
the log-likelihood of the of some held
out data so D prime here is data that
your model hasn't seen before if you
have a model that always predicts cat
and you have a held out corpus that only
contains the word cat well then your
look like is going to be good but that's
not a particularly good topic model so
doesn't it this measure doesn't tell you
anything of how well the semantics of
the corpus have been captured so how
would that what would a measure look
like that would capture that now ignore
that we have a model there is no model
let's just for
I'll think about what kind of how would
we describe concepts and how could we
capture the semantic coherence of those
concepts if we want it to so here's two
documents that talk about ice hockey the
first one talks about the first one is
about demo seven the second one is about
Pekka Rinne both finish ice hockey
players now if I I now assert to you
that these are the words that sort of
capture the semantics of the concept of
ice hockey this is what it means for
something to be related to ice hockey
sort of roughly speaking so we have
words that are clearly related to ice
hockey the names of ice hockey leagues
and ice hockey teams names of ice hockey
players but then there's all sorts of
general stuff like shots which is
definitely related to ice hockey but we
just see shorts sort of out of context
without these documents you might
associate that rather with a no shooting
so let's take this further and I'll just
I'll just remove the words that are the
unrelated words and now we have two sets
of words and now we can say that okay
well this is now what we say is the
meaning of ice hockey you can see where
this is going right this is the output
that you get from a topic model so okay
so what would then capture if we were
given this description of the category
of ice hockey how would we capture the
semantic coherence of this description
of the category from some data well we
can use a measure that does that and
this is there's quite a bit of research
that has been done on this this is one
of the measures and what you see here is
essentially the conditional likelihood
of the words occurring with each other
but notice that the conditional
likelihood is capturing information
about two terms so there's some context
there it is in context-free like the log
like the perplexity measure was before
so now we can take those words that we
defined and then
go and look at some reference corpus and
measure probabilities and then use this
measure and there you go sorry
this is iterating over words or word
well I'm sorry I'll get to that in just
a moment so this research has sort of
encapsulated the various different ways
of doing of measuring that confirmation
that metric that well yeah the metric
that I just showed so this is the last
paper I read at all this is actually
implemented partially in Jensen not all
of the measures metrics are available
there but most of them are so what this
is doing is so first you do segmentation
which is the exact sort of putting the
words together that I just showed then
you have some way of calculating the
probabilities get to that later then you
compute this confirmation measure which
is the thing that I just showed you and
then you do aggregation which basically
just means that you take you take the
mean they do a number of different
aggregation measures and but essentially
it's take the mean so let's see what
this looks like in practice I'm going to
take this pipeline as or this topic 9
here this is the same model that you saw
before and then you do segmentation this
is what you compute the measure over tau
yeah okay so you do segmentation there's
a lot of different ways of doing
segmentation so you take the top words
from the model and then you do pairs of
words or you do pairs of pairs or you do
pairs of triples and so on and so on you
decide how you do that you compute your
confirmation measure which uses in this
case probabilities not all of them use
probabilities others are sort of vector
similarity things so you compute these
probabilities you need to have a way of
computing the probabilities so maybe you
just use the document level probability
of the words occurring this is from a
reference corpus that the model hasn't
seen ideally
and then you get a number this first one
so right so you get a model this is 35
topics you do some segmentation you do
some way of calculating probability then
you compute some confirmation measure
for the similarity of the stuff and then
you do aggregation which this you should
just replace internally as the mean and
then you get didn't you get a number out
which this measure is the one that they
develop in the paper and it's a it's a
combination of vector similarity of the
words and the NPM I so I'm not exactly
sure what the scale of this function is
but I think it's between minus 1 and 1
or you can do you can take the same
thing would compute a different
conformation measure and then you get a
different number out which is in a
different scale so that's not exactly
helpful then you can do that you can
feed in a model that has more topics
than this model and you get a number
that is again different from the second
one but now look at the scale here how'd
like I place this model three times as
bad as that model well I don't know
because the scale is just undefined okay
and you can write you understand the
problem here so this is I think it's a
step in the right direction but there's
a few issues here so first of all you're
these pairs of words that you're
computing from your top top words in the
model you're taking the mean over those
there's going to be a lot of pairs so
you're computing the mean over a lot of
things you have no understanding of what
the variances this isn't included in the
pipeline so you have no way of knowing
whether this value that you get out is
that actually representative of the
overall sort of similarities that you've
just inferred the different values are
not really comparable I'm pretty sure
you could do some normalization but that
would be extra research you need to be
really really careful what your
reference corpus is so you're measuring
the probabilities that
are fed into this confirmation measure
from a reference corpus now if you're
just doing Wikipedia you're probably
fine you have enough data on Wikipedia
to do an 80/20 split and use the 20 as
your reference corpus for instance but
if you're doing some domain specific
thing like I don't know topic modeling
on legal documents well they tend not to
be that many legal documents openly
available and the data sets that you
might have may not be big enough for you
to split them the problem is that legal
text doesn't look anything like the text
that you get from Wikipedia so if you
compute the if you use as reference
corpus Wikipedia you're going to get
really weird sort of probabilities or
similarities out of the reference corpus
not because your model is wrong but just
because the two corpora that you're
using don't actually match in terms of
the words or in terms of the statistics
that you see there and then the other
problem is that you so it could be the
case theoretically that this 100 topic
model which is clearly worse than the 35
topic model actually has so this hundred
topic model has all the 35 topics that
that this model has captured it then has
captured say an extra ten topics that
this thing didn't capture but then all
the rest are junk right so you have 45
topics that are good and then you have
55 topics that are junk
well those junk topics can cause this to
be worse but does it really mean like if
you look at the model you can tell what
the junk topics are you can just see
them right away and go okay those are
relevant I'd like to just ignore them
but the 45 that you got are actually
better than the 35 that you got here but
that's not reflected in this measure
so finally human judgment based methods
again research this is sort of coming
off the fact that at some point people
notice that oh yeah perplexity is a bad
thing to do so let's try to figure
what's what's nicer so in the reading
tea leaves paper they develop two
different tasks to measure how well the
predictions of the model correspond to
our intuitions of what topics are or
should be so they do word intrusion so
you have a set of words again these are
taken from the stop words from the model
from a topic and then you insert a word
that is has low probability for a topic
and high probability for some other
topic so it's intruding in the semantics
of this one topic and here most people
will say that it's pig so the the the
predictions of the humans on what the
intruding word is converge to a single
entry whereas if you have a topic that
is semantically incoherent they'll just
be all over the place and you can tell
from the gist from the spread of the
predictions that you get from the humans
that that this particular model is not
sort of semantically consistent with
itself then there's our task which is
topic intrusion so this is how you get a
the title from a document and the
snippet and then when you run this
document to the topic model you get a
probability distribution over the topic
so you take a few of these top ones and
then you take one or two maybe just one
of the really bottom ones the really
like this document is really not about
these topics and then you get something
like this so you have the two top ones
are sort of supposed to be the like
belong to the document like the document
talks of is of these topics and then the
bottom one is sort of this is one of the
low ranked ones and again the same time
it's the set up is exactly the same as
for word interview the problem here is
that it's relatively difficult to
determine you usually very rarely get
really sort of clean-cut topics so it's
very difficult often to the
Terman what the intruding what the
interviewing topic is okay
so in summary topic models are difficult
to evaluate the you can do qualitative
qualitative evaluation but it's it's
labor-intensive
and often very very subjective
quantitative analysis relies on all
kinds of issues that you did have to
deal with basically when you're dealing
with humans open-source software is
available there's also lots of research
that's available you know as open access
but the real take-home point here is
that it you cannot define a universally
good model it does not exist because it
depends on what you want the model to do
it depends on what you're trying to
achieve now the final point if I may
just run over time a little bit is the
question of so the reason why these
things are difficult to evaluate is
because we don't have a proper
definition for what I don't know what
coherence means or what do we mean when
when we say a concept right it's
essentially the question is what are
words so I have a short video here is
the sound on
there is no Sun okay forget it so a news
clip it's funny basically this this guy
is talking about Trump and he's asking
the question what does he mean when he
says words does he mean the words or
does he mean something like the words
and this is indeed a good question
because what is the what like how how
some how reasonable is it to expect sets
of words to consistently capture
concepts that we have in our heads of
what exists in the world like how many
words would you need to I don't know
capture ice hockey and would the person
next to you pick those same words would
they understand the same category so cat
dog pet rabbit horse are pets animals
but if I change a few of the words then
this topic is these cats or is it
inconsistent snowball could refer to the
cat in Simpsons but then dog is a kind
of an outlier so maybe that's an
interesting word and at all
and then also cat and dog are not like
often when you're this problem isn't
limited to just topic models this is all
unsupervised sort of NLP including word
vectors often cat and dog will get a
similar vector you'll there because
they're sort of similar things right but
they can also be the opposites of each
other so if you're talking about cat
people and dog people then they are
semantically precisely the polar
opposites of each other but there's
currently no like we don't really know
how to capture that at the moment thank
you very much
[Applause]
I'm going to answer your questions
really slowly we also have one and a
half hours for lunch so it's not Lev I
can I can repeat the question it's fine
yeah maybe I'm balling here we go you
mean this one yeah this light is very
confusing to me because very confusing
for most people I've learned like
principal components analysis we have
principal cordons it's principle
coordinate analysis it's not principal
components analysis I see but okay
what's the difference in principal
coordinates now just a metric Automotion
scaling you're gonna going to read the
papers yourself okay man yeah also so
the third algorithm for this is tease me
uh-huh but again they're like they just
all work they do dimensionality
reduction but how exactly they do that
take a take a weekend off and go read
the paper like if you look at the file
Davis for the okapi Oh Davis for example
they're they use PCA which is principal
why people they use know by default they
use principle coordinate analysis on PC
Oh a okay let's let might explain things
better cool but just ok then I'll have a
side note about coherence so you
mentioned that coherence is not useful
sort of no way yeah ok no that's not
what I'm trying to say I'm saying that
it's not without its faults you
shouldn't but if you use if you like run
the
the coherence pipeline in Jensen and you
get a big number out it will give you an
understanding but it's a more mundane
everyday problem which coherence solves
and Jensen there isn't hydrants was
added to Jensen is because when you
train LD a model like convey TPJ over
like two days and any state running no
no this is I I presented some criticism
of Jen's no just like no like just the
reason it's been edited there's more
mundane technical problem when your
trainer of the model for a while like
your perplexity yeah like okay that's
fine
okay no but I agree with the point that
you're trying to make that it is useful
my motivation for this talk is to say
that evaluating these things is really
difficult the fact that you get a number
out don't it doesn't mean that you have
a good model necessary it doesn't mean
that you have the model that you want it
to have okay Mira
PCO a so bcoa versus MDS one thing you
kind of hinted at but you didn't make
very explicit it's that these are
actually very complicated based in their
own right and you're taking Lda or HTTP
whatever completely unsupervised lots of
moving parts some have more free
parameters than others but you get
something very different each time and
then you can't see what it's doing
obviously because it's a hundred
dimensional if you have a hundred topics
so you go all I know I'm just going to
reduce that down to two dimensions but
the way you do that is completely master
all these things are throwing away a
different amount of information and
they're making different sacrifices and
even worse they have a lot of
non-determinism they have a lot of free
parameters like T's Nino and I don't
know if seen it there was a really good
blog post recently about tease me that
have like 20 things you can turn and
then going on I think I put the blog
post in the in the node that's a very
good one no reading on how exactly you
set those knobs you end up with
completely different rails so bear in
mind that this is a very harsh reduction
of information down to 2d just because
we can think of it in any more than 2d
yeah yes that is a very valid point
thank you but it doesn't so that doesn't
really like as such reduce the
functionality or the utility of this
this is you do as you see here but you
do actually get these groupings of
documents or topics that are
semantically related
it's just that determining exactly how
related is again a little difficult this
is the exact same model with the
dimensionality reduction in two
different ways so are 10 and 15 close
semantically or I mean in one picture
yes in the other they're on the opposite
side of the coordinate system what are
you supposed to make of that information
other questions yes in practice
should I just choose the model a little
closer yeah in practice do all of the
above well again but it depends on what
you want like yeah use the visualization
tools to gain a kind of an understanding
whether roughly the sort of thing that
you are expecting to find in the model
is there look at the metrics look at
perplexity if you want look at the
metrics and then sort of compare the
results on the outputs of those but
don't just like look at one thing and go
okay that's fine we're we're done it do
you think that is the long way right so
kind of a good practice I've learnt I
don't always do is kind of to define
what is the good result before I
actually start evaluating right yeah
that's yeah so that's one way of doing
that's often difficult because often
what you the reason why you pick up
topic modeling is because you don't know
what's in the corpus and you're hoping
that the topic model will tell you so
it's but yeah may again depending a
little bit on your on your use case may
be you can define what a good what a
good output would be but if you're just
trying to understand the semantic
composition of the of the corpus then I
don't really know how you would even
define that
that was you know when you spoke about
the current evolution measure when it
actually has a high measure does it mean
that most of the words in a single topic
are actually found closer in the
reference text or something yeah yeah so
the way the again this hold on well
we're talking about this right yeah yeah
so overall all of the confirmation
measures these things that give you the
actual metric work in precisely that way
so lower number is worse and higher
number is better yeah okay but it's
again you can't really like telling the
difference between the scales of the
different measures is there was a
question in front here and then Barkov
yes thanks for the talk
I was wondering first practical amateur
question if you've got your model with a
lot of topics a lot of dimensions maybe
for each topic and you reduce it to two
so you can plot it nicely and as the guy
over there said you can do that anywhere
you want and you can probably end up
getting more us any representation you
want like we saw two comparisons
completely different yeah absolutely
the first amateur question once you do
that and you put it and you say okay it
looks good like findt and then trump
next to each other so I think that's
probably a good model mm-hmm when what
do can you use the two dimensions that
you drop down to to do further modeling
or do you always go back and use the
bigger either I don't know what the two
dimensions mean yeah but do you know
what the 100 mean that went down to two
anyway
well so the yeah so the 100 is or so
okay so let's say that you have a 100
topic model so you have a 100 by 100
topic similarity matrix so those those
dimensions you do know you you know
exactly the similarity of you know topic
10 to topic 12 because it's in the
matrix
that's so they're using the normalized
kullbackleibler divergence to measure
that similarity so that gives you a like
a precise understanding of how it's
being measured and what what that number
represents
but that matrix is then cut down by one
of three different algorithms or I don't
know a fourth one if you can propose one
or have one you know ready what the
interpretation of the remain dimensions
are depends on the algorithm okay then
my follow-up question is more just like
an idea than our comment which is if you
were to interpret there compressed
version and your plot and you say your
model is good based on that
visualization which we've seen can be
completely bogus like so what's to argue
against just saying where you want
trouble Clinton to be workout an
algorithm that would get them there
based on your stuff so is there any yeah
point in these tea slaving you know you
normally don't insert the answer that
you want into the method that is trying
to give you the answer that's I'm you a
will that I will you cover with that
yeah yeah you could do that and you
would probably get the answer you wanted
but how do you now know if the answer is
valid okay but also the barkhov hadn't
had a question I'm sorry I'm not sure if
your yes answer this in the first half
of your talk because I was in there
furth yeah I want to know if you think
are there different kinds of metrics
depending on what you're using the LDA
model for for example if you a and he's
all for clustering or something is a
better metric do you think any of these
measuring but what do you want to
cluster but I'm just saying if depending
on what you want to do the traffic
models do
and you have so the obvious like the
obvious answer to that is yes there's if
you're using an external task that's
your metric if you're if you're using
law if you're doing clustering well then
you can do oh yes oh one thing that I
didn't actually mention at all is we've
in relation to clustering so you can
also like measure this hold on right
this is the ideal output from an Lda
from a topic model so you could there's
a bunch of sort of an unknown network
analysis methods and clustering metrics
that are completely unrelated to topic
modeling they're just generic clustering
metrics that allows you to measure how
sort of how separated these clusters are
between themselves so you could use
something like that if what you want to
get out of the model is clusters that
are separated that's not always the case
thank you very much
[Applause]